Is there an oatmeal that is good for you?
Well, I wouldn't say any oatmeal is bad for you,
except what you really have to be careful with oatmeal is okay.
Going back to the gluten issue.
All oatmeal is going to be cross-contaminated with gluten,
unless it says it's gluten-free oatmeal.
So because oats and wheat are typically stored in the same storehouses,
you're going to have cross-contamination on gluten to oatmeal.
So technically, oatmeal has gluten in it,
but it's going to be cross-contaminated.
Secondly, oatmeal, unless it says organic,
is definitely going to be filled with glyphosate.
So you should not be eating any non-organic oatmeal.
So if you're staying off of gluten,
you should be eating gluten-free organic oatmeal.
You should not be eating non-organic oatmeal
because it is definitely going to be related with glyphosate.
And glyphosate is definitely a driver of cancer.
So if it's organic and it's gluten-free,
then by all means there's anything wrong with oatmeal.
The other issue that you could have with,
should everybody just be eating organic gluten-free oatmeal?
Well, no, it's also got carbohydrate.
So if you're trying to keep your glucose levels down,
then you shouldn't be just eating the whole bunch of oatmeal, right?
So you have to address that.
Now, if a person has got low to average weight,
or if a person is in cakexia,
they're losing weight on a weekly basis,
then oatmeal is one of the things that I recommend.
But again, it's organic oatmeal that you're looking for,
so it doesn't have glyphosate in it.